لحظات الاولى
بدا من هنا وانتشر بموجاته في العشر
ولايات الاخرى مع هزته الاستداديه
مع الوفيات الان ثمن الاف 8000
واربعه
وسبعين
وعدد المباني المنهاره هو
افاده من
6400 مبنى
من المهم الى نقطه مهمه هنا صبر
واعتقد ان الشعب الان والمواطنين سيظهرون
هذا الصبر هنا ايضا باستمرار
جهودنا
هنا في كل
المدن المتضرره من هذا الزلزال افادت
تتراس عمليه التنسيق هو الانقاذ والبحث مع
البلديه ومع القوات الاخرى والفرق الاخرى
في كل مدينه
وزير مع يتابع كل المجريات
بعض المشاكل في الوصول الى المناطق
المكتوبه والى
المباني المنار ولكن
الان ان نسيطر
بنسبه ممكنه الى هذه
المدن وصنن لهذه المدن وايضا المباني ولكن
الان نعمل
عمليه رفع الانقاذ كلها واعاده اعمار
المنطقه في اسرع وقتا ممكن ممكن
طبعا الحد
لهذا
الموجود وسنحقق الاعمار في سنه
المدن وفي كل حصلت في
الاشهر وسنوات الماضيه في عدد مختلف من
المدن
لن نترك اي مواطن في الشارع بالطبع سنساعد
الجميع وسنقدم المساعدات للجميع علينا ان
ننوه ايضا
طبعا هناك فنادق في انطاليا
ونستمر بالحديث رايهم التواصل واياهم
ونحن سنوجه المواطنين ايضا الى هناك
المتضررين من الزلازل الى سنرسلهم الى
هناك
وسناؤمن لهم الاقامه في هذه الفنادق في
الانيا وانطاليا
وصلنا الى عدد غرف لا باس به يمكن
للمتضررين ان يقيموا هناك طبعا من الممكن
ان يكون المتضررين من الزلزال سعيدين هنا
نحن نعلم ان المخيمات ظروفها صعبه واذا
وافقوا على التوجه الى هذه المدن فنحن
سنساعدهم بالذهاب الى هذه المدن والاقامه
هناك وسناؤهل لهم كل الامكانيات لكي يقيم
هناك بشكل مؤقت الى ان يتم اعمار هذه
المناطق وطبعا سيتم تحديد
المنسقين في هذا الاطار
ليحملوا لينقلوا عفوا
المنتظرين من هذه الزلازل الى المدن
الاخرى التاليه
اقامتهم هناك في حال طبعا النقل
المواطنين من هنا الى تلك المدن فنسهل
سنسهل ايضا عمليه
الانقاذ والبحث هنا اكثر في البدايه كان
هناك مشاكل في الطرق في المطارات ولكن
الان نحن حققنا
تامين هذه الطرق وتامين المطارات هناك بعض
المشاكل ايضا في تامين بعض
المحروقات مثلا او المواد الاخرى ولكن
نتغلب عليها شيئا فشيء ميلونجاز ايضا
يساعدوننا في تقديم المحروقات وانابيب
الغاز ايضا الى هذه المدن من اجل تامين
الطهي والدفء وايضا الاحتياجات الاخرى
لذلك
من المهم الان العمل على
تامين العيش بشكل كريم هنا ونحن طبعا
سنؤمن كل الاحتياجات هنا ولكن من الافضل
اذا استطعنا ان ننقل المصابين او
المتضررين من
الزلزال بدل يقيم في هذه المخيمات
بامكانهم ان يقيموا فيه الفنادق في المدن
المختلفون نحن سنؤمن كل اجور ذلك ايضا من
المهم جدا عدم السماح
للتصريحات
الاستفزازيه والاخبار المستفزه وايضا
الاخبار الكاذبه التي تنتشر على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي من المهم الان ان نركز
على عمليات البحث وانقاذ والتضامن في هذا
الاطار هناك بعض الاستعدادات
لتشخيص الاضرار الموجوده هنا في هذه المدن
ايضا سنقدم الدعم للاسر المتضرره من هذه
الزلازل تم تحديد
بعضره
وسنستمر كما ذكرنا اننا سنشخص كل الاضرار
الموجوده وبعد ذلك سنهتم بالاسر
ونخصص للاسر الان تقريبا 10,000 ليره
تركيه
لتامين احتياجاتهم الاوليه
الانه تعالى ولكن نحن
اسهل عليهم هذه المرحله قدر المستطاع شكرا
جزيلا